bonsoir jean claude van damme délicat un
lan délicat qui a le geste qu'ils
s'essuient très légèrement la bouche
avant d'embrasser d'accord d'accord non
mais c'est parce que c'est pas mon
emploi bien jean claude brialy donc
après le succès du ruisseau des singes
sept cent mille exemplaires
miracle et il est pas sortie à lourdes
c'est un an vraiment un miracle gros
succès alors après on vous a demandé
d'écrire une seconde autobiographie où
j'ai problème penser à l'om si vous
n'avez qu'une vie donc c'est compliqué
d'écrire deux autobus non parce que
j'avais envoyé 950 places à la première
soit 1 et puis j'avais enlevé quatre
cents pages donc géré puiser dans
lesquels 100 pages et comme il y avait
10 ans qui s'était passé celui là
s'appelle j'ai oublié de vous dire chez
xo éditions c'est toujours en tête des
ventes je n'ai vendu 350 mille deux cent
cinquante mille en trois semaines oh la
la alors vous raconter des tas
d'anecdotes évidemment comme d'habitude
c'est super drôle par exemple sacha
guitry moi je savais pas que quand il
est tombé amoureux yvonne printemps il
allait promener son chien mais mais
surtout il avait installé un judas pour
la survoler la chambre de sa femme est
la sienne et il ya bien un passe plat
entre les deux pour voir si elle était
toujours là il y avait une petite pieds
en or il l'enfermé après l'avoir honorer
un compte bien faire mais il l'enfermé
pour pas qu'elle sorte oui et non elle a
connu pire freiner ouais tiens freiner
s'est mis dans un arbre en face de la
chambre la fenêtre de yvonne printemps
et avec sa cigarette user du morse pour
lui dire je parle
voilà
le problème le problème s'est construit
elle y sera plus là pour vous raconter
toutes ces belles histoires voulez vous
dirait mon livre la mer la chaise comme
disait le luron elle sera plus là la
merde h f alors pierre brasseur lui
s'est fait piquer sa femme par une autre
femme ça ça le faisait chier parce qu'il
disait quand même assez d'elle c'est un
peu de ma faute il vient dans mon tout
petit appartement pour réveillonner eh
bien avec sa femme qui était une grande
pianiste très très belle et très élégant
de très charmante et moi j'habitais avec
une copine qui avait sais pas où dormir
qui s'appelait picoler du collège bon
donc un pic honnête elle était un peu
comme ça ma repos pour le coacher la est
tombée amoureuse de la femme de pierre
bon alors je lui dit de se calmer je
suis mon copain tu es mon ami tu es
folle ou quoi et l'autre malheureusement
est tombée amoureuse de picoler est donc
l ombre et sont partis ensemble alors
pierre maudoux d'or cocu mallet je veux
bien me parut
alors elles ont monté un restaurant il
avait laissé ça il avait laissé une
maison qu'il avait à grimaud à sa femme
parce qu'il était très élégant et très
généreux et puis la preuve que l on fait
du un très bon restaurant qui était la
coqueluche de la côte d'azur alors
pierre ces furieux ils descendent dans
le midi ils étaient complètement bourré
il va à grimaud y rentrer dans le
restaurant qui se fait don il ya tous
les clients qui bouffaient tibet il nous
a bright eyes peas
et voilà ce que je fais et s'était
trompé de restaur
[Applaudissements]
voilà alors on apprend dans ce week-end
j'avais été là monde ava gardner mon
cher jean claude brialy dans quelles
circonstances c'était un miracle comme
le la réussite du livre j'étais à rome
je tournais un film et puis elle est
d'être bon et lagardère elle est
magnifique et là bingo d'années et elle
m'a choisi c'est elle qui m'a moselle
elle était très comment dirais-je elle
sortait d'un une histoire d'amour avec
un grand acteur comique qui s'appelait
valter khiari donc elle buvait beaucoup
elle allait de boîte en boîte de
restaurants restaurant moi j'étais
mignon elle m'a vue elle m'a mangé tout
cru et voilà et j'étais très heureux
parce que
d'abord j'ai eu beaucoup de fiancés au
début de ma carrière j'ai choisi plus
tard mais en montant les escaliers des
suisses l'excelsior je me suis dit la
tête de belmondo et de longs
matches mais je fais le patcher on
apprend que je n'étais lamanda lagardère
mais aussi de rudolf noureev ce que je
ne savais pas c'était une scène aux
reliques extraordinaire dans un hôtel
particulier aux yeux je raconte ça parce
que c'est drôle parce que c'était à
londres luchino visconti donné à grand
dîner parce que pour noureev et puis
c'était un truc assez chic assez dégarni
relief était habillé comme un muschick
jamais du smoking mais avec un charme
fou on le met en face d'eux le kilo moi
j'étais très jeune à l'époque donc on
met au bout de la table vont très bien
et puis au bout de cinq minutes je sens
une
oreillette qui s'ennuyait commencé comme
ça ça le fait chier il se lève et samba
et en passant devant moi il me jette un
petit bout de papier devant tout le
monde alors bonjour
je regarde et il y avait son numéro de
téléphone appel et voilà je vous l'avais
appelé we call me baby mini stage
j'avais compris bon ben je rentre à
l'hôtel après avoir envisagé ce que le
dessert est arrivé enfin j'étais assez
impatient il était la beauté même buste
un danseur magique
de corps bien fait non mais c'était un
danseur magique aux offres et puis
beaucoup à la maison aussi
je sais que je sorte de l'hôtel je
prends mon taxi je vais retrouver le
danseur russe ça et puis l'autre et des
robes de chambre rouge avec des sièges
partout il y avait de la musique on va
sauter la police champagne et j'ai fait
dans la nuit je croise est douze fois
paris saint pétersbourg général comme ça
quoi j'étais donc très heureux c'est
discret quand même sur ce qui sépare
vous ressortez avec l'arrivée 6 heures
du matin raconte alors là ce moment là
par l'uci avait des cierges partout je
pense que c'est le rêve voilà alors y'a
plein de choses dans ce bouquin ya
charles trenet dont on apprend qu'il
faisait jamais rien sans être payés vous
dit de l'argent l'argent le faisait
jouer oui oui mais en même temps je dis
aussi que c'était le plus grand poète
qu'on a eu dans la chanson -
l'admiration que j'ai pour lui mais sans
borne simplement un horrible demande je
me demande de venir chanter ramatuelle
pour la dernière fois il avait 75 ans il
dit je ne chante plus mais je pour toi
je veux ni rabat où elle s'est rabattue
ljc près de saint tropez bon il 17 ans
alors je dis bon ben on va essayer de
payer c'est beaucoup beaucoup d'argent
je m'arrange je trouve des sponsors des
médecins etc il vient et on peut
l'appeler contre mehdi 12h05 alors
j'appelle à 12h04 et je lui dis tu
n'oublies pas que le doubs de 13 août tu
viens chanter à ramatuelle on avait un
contrat mais enfin comme il est étrange
ml oui mais rien alors il ferait tout
simplement que tu viens de me remettre
un prix que j'ai eu le plus grand prix
au canada
au québec alors j'ai dû m'écouter
charles sais c'est un gros voyage ouais
mais viens viens me sinon je viens pas
chanter je vais donc au québec là on lui
demande de chanter deux chansons me les
papilles et chante pas dont je remets le
prix dans sa voiture va il vient pas on
va tu as été un folie totale et puis
enfin arrive le jour de ramatuelle et
deux jours avant ils téléphonent disant
écoute j'ai un colloque tu veux venir
fatah balance et nuit je serai là six
heures jusqu'à 6 heures pour nous
accueillir et puis d'un coup il me
téléphone en fait et les fleurs bizarres
je virais à 8h bon je me serais là 8
heures ça commençait à 9h30 et bien ce
que tu as bien pas une n'est pas l'hôtel
sympathique parce que je suis un gentil
mais je serai fatigué après le changer
mais bien sûr j'ai un très bon hôtel à
ramatuelle où il ya cinq étoiles enfin
formidable un nom m'a parlé d'un petit
hôtel sympathique à saint tropez byblos
et sabine à 13 août non je téléphone au
patron du byblos que je connais pas
mais qui me dit monsieur brialy pour
monsieur trenet j'adore monsieur trenet
je vais j'ai pas de place mais je
m'arrangeais il faut des allemands d'or
il trouver une grande chambre opposable
à ray charles à 8 heures et prend le
micro comme ça je vais n'est pas bon ce
micro annoncé celui qu'on a dû renoncer
à pathé marconi non non non c'est le
micro d'amérique nous a demandé non non
non c'est pas bon ça ça grésille je ne
peux pas chanter donc je chante pas
alors je cours après lui je lui dis mais
c'est ton micro et y avait heureusement
ce merveilleux nicolas qui était le
contrebassiste de base bon lui qui était
trempée dans l'eau dans le vin blanc et
le père noël matin dès le matin donc il
était complètement pété je dis monsieur
nicolas ça serait gentil de médée dit
que charles trenet à une très jolie la
voie alors il va s'asseoir et ça avant
que charles commencé à chanter dit il a
une très jolie vous j'ai dénoncé peu
après il faut le dire mais enfin bon et
la main il chante 30 chansons sublimes
sublimissime merveilleux et des belles
chansons qu'on connaît et après je dis
tu sais le président d'air inter tu as
fait un dîner 250 personnes qu'il reste
un quart d'heure j'y vais pas alors
comment ça a du charme jeudi jouer de
faire une table à pas avec tes amis
alors on avait mis au milieu jean lemay
d'un côté j'appelle jean pierre aumont
jabel des amis charmant et puis il
commence à voir un petit peu de vin
blanc il était heureux tout allait bien
et commence à agir aujourd'hui une
petite chanson et puis on arrive le
président d'air inter qui avait quand
même donné 10 briques pour veut le faire
venir et le président des interludes il
joue vraiment c'est une des plus belles
soirées j'aurais passé alors moi je les
ai pas pour le prix c'est normal bon et
charles jeune et regarde le président
des intérêts dit je t'ai pas ma carte
évasion
et 30%
et après il ya le patron du byblos qui
passe il dit finalement je vais rentrer
et là on en arrive alors à ce qui est de
plus ce coup pesc dans votre lit on a
envie de vous scoop est ce assez joli
ces îles montant oui voilà que je n'ai
pas de main morte avec yves montand ah
oui alors vous dites qu'ils les
truqueurs voleurs et joueur escroc
infidèle lâche la tête de déterré des
[Rires]
sas et enfin ça m'étonne d'autant qu'on
le seul moment où l'on rendait hommage à
farina c'est pour dire qu'il était
sincère dans ses engagements politiques
mais qui s'est trompé puisqu'il pensait
que staline était un mec formidable
voilà alors enfin c'est à résumer un peu
approximatif on va raconter d'histoires
parce que les gens ils la connaissent
pas l'histoire donc en fait ça a
commencé quand mon temps a fait une
émission à la télévision qui s'appelait
vive la crise et pour faire cette
émission vient de la crise il avait
touché 800 mille balles voilà et un jour
vous allez manquer ce qui était énorme
voilà il avait touché 800 mille bas 80
millions d'anciens 80 millions d'anciens
francs et il demandé dans cette émission
aux gens de se serrer la ceinture de
faire un effort et un jour dans mon
zénith à moi denisot vous vous dit mais
vous n'êtes pas engagé par rapport à
yves montand diamant vous faites rien
etc et vous vous dites mais moi si c'est
pour gagner huit cent mille balles pour
dire aux gens de se serrer la ceinture
je veux bien le faire et à ce moment là
mon temps vous appelle non il ya eu un
quiproquo c'est qu'après il y avait un
jeune homme qui s'appelait lamy qui est
un imitateur entre l année qui était un
jeune belge et lundi ou mardi on va
prendre un jeune pour pour couper les
missions de être trouvé sympathique je
ne savais pas ce qu'il faisait un et il
a imité montant dans le pape et kirk
hammet ses huit cent mille balles donc
j'ai trouvé que c'était un peu too much
jeudi à denisot j tu crois pas que c'est
un peu ça fait appuyer un peu parce que
ce n'était pas dans le programme il me
dit non non tu verras et le lendemain
matin j'ai un coup de téléphone de mon
temps qui me tais dit qu'il veut me
casser la gueule que je suis une [ __ ]
un [ __ ] que un sale [ __ ] spd et
doivent être tous les maux le charmant
alors que et il se trouve que huit jours
avant j'avais déjeuné avec un ami pour
lui demander de l'argent pour abattue
elle qui était de chez dents elf un
vieux monsieur qui avait 82 ans et qui
me dit je me suis fait mon temps je lui
dit comment tu peux dire une chose
pareille c'est ce qu'on dit de long
parce que tout le monde va accoucher de
lens qui est faux ce que moi j'étais là
quand j'ai enfin on a commencé ensemble
elle a vécu comme des copains et non et
c'est vrai donc je suis j'aime pas qu'on
raconte n'importe quoi alors minimes et
non pas du tout et en plus il était
l'amant de rédac est rédacteur qui était
un immense chanteur genre jean lumière
vint qui j'ai gentiment aussi à
marseille a dénoncé jeudi mais c'est pas
possible il me dit oui alors je
téléphone à quelques amis apportant un
du music houle qui me confirme usa tout
le monde le sait il a été mais mais pas
ils étaient pas homosexuel non puisqu'il
était homophobe oui la balle était
homophobe mais surtout il était il
aimait les femmes mais pour réussir il
avait passé par là donc malvenu
si l école est quelqu'un qui attend qui
doit sauter bombe sexuelle voilà c'est
passé passé ils étaient homosexuels
arrêtés il ya un moment donné ou à
passer sur un c'est sur l'un de l'autre
je ne porte pas de jugement là-dessus
l'avortement regarde pas sa mère sûr
mais il était mal vu mais à ce moment là
vous dit à yves montand qui vous traite
de tout dix ans je lis simplement au
téléphone je lui ai dit écoute tu
écoutes une seconde la red à coeur un
silence absolu et et voilà
non mais pas de verbe gens non je vais
vous dire c'est pas très grave ce que je
veux dire c'est que ça vient au moment
de l'interview moment de benjamin
castaldi ne serait pas j'en trouverais
ça je dois dire que si j'avais su que le
livre devrait sortir avec le on ne tente
le mien je n'aurais pas mis ailleurs
dans la première version que j'ai de
l'eau jolie consécration theillet tma
ah bon j'avais enlevé ah oui alors vous
le derby j'ai enlevé j'ai remis mon
entourage m'a dit ne le met pas parce
que les journalistes vont parler que de
ça
c'est un professionnel
je ne raconte pas des trucs bizarres
comme c'est papa non mais à 18 ans
tripoter c'est pas en même temps un
homme qui couche avec un autre homme et
qu'il ya un autre ténor capelette c'est
juste ça je suis sympa quoi
se venger de ce qui vous a dit ce jour
là non j'ai été blessé pendant longtemps
et j'étais très malheureux que quelqu'un
que j'admirais comme lui quand comme
intelligente entre vous et moi quoi
qu'il n'était pas apte les gens et puis
il avait fait beaucoup de mal à simone
signoret et puis de dire dans le livre
de sa ducati dit que marilyn monroe
n'était pas à coup un moi qui vous parle
j'aurais bien aimé dormir et perd sa
femme est à la bagarre n'a été faute
maintenant
parler de quoi je me mêle en tout cas
totu pressé tranquille là je te ferai
rien c'est dégueulasse
et puis un jour
en tous les cas ces gens là vous ont
laissé des souvenirs parce que les gens
vous voyez aujourd'hui va vous racontiez
le jour dans sud ouest par exemple vous
avez déjeuné avec laetitia casta vous
dites on a parlé de la corse et de son
fiancé mais rien de plus c'est que c'est
sûr vous n'avez pas de vivre à écrire
sur ce qui vous est arrivé avec laetitia
casta c'est vrai que elle elle est jeune
et qu'elle n'a pas une vie mouvementée
ce que je raconte dans mon livre ce sont
les gens qui ont eu des accidents ou des
choses extravagantes en moyenne chose
qui me fascine dans ce métier quand
j'avais 17 ans j'ai commencé dans ce
métier
par la figuration je faisais des
carpentier un jour je tabbee en petit à
petit marin et ben ma première rencontre
avec shaw vice et s était alors alors tu
as mis le doigt dans l'oeil
ne s'est pas senti très mal
bon alors on va faire
une interview oui qui va vous permettre
d'enfin parler de vous tu peux parler
normalement il entend y compris oui bout
d'un coup j'ai l'impression qu'ils
croient que c'est charles vanel
il était bien trop tard car la belle
balade charge amel bent pardon là parce
que je suis aujourd'hui elle fait un
quart d'heure le ce extraordinaire on va
parler de lui maintenant on va faire une
interview miroir méline
[Musique]
jean-claude oui il ressemble à quoi
l'homme que vous voyez dans ce miroir
il faudrait qu'ils perdent 15 kg
il en a vu beaucoup des vertes et des
pas mûres il a les cheveux blancs parce
qu'il s'est fait du souci tant temps
puis voilà vous lui donnez quel âge
comme ça
moi je n'aime pas donner d âge qui est
entre 60 et 70 ans vous trouvez comment
cet homme je ne m'aime pas moi j'aime
pas me regarder il y avait beaucoup de
ce film j'ai pas vu de moi contiennent
des missions de des gens que j'ai
enregistrée qui passe à tour je regarde
pas donc ne nous mettez pas un miroir en
phase ii voici justement qu'est-ce qui
vous plaît pas dans cet homme
non mais
si je ne m'aimais pas je vivrai pas avec
moi je me serais suicidé depuis
longtemps de je m'accepte mais enfin je
me trouve parfois brillant drôle
méchant
gourmands
cet homme que vous voyez vous voulez pas
regarder la mer heureux qui a que les
imbéciles qui sont heureux mais comment
on peut être heureux quand le matin vous
mettez votre radio m'a jamais tôt le
matin on entend qu à la guerre en irak
qui a la palestine qui a les élections
au bouge qui a le sida qui a des enfants
qui meurent de faim vous pouvez être
heureux il reste la drogue l'alcool et
les tranquillisants lavalin alors moi je
me drogue pas et je ne prends pas
tranquillisants il a l'air très polis
comme ça vous pensez qu'il peut dire des
gros mots cet homme est dit des gros
mots et puis les révoltés surtout n'est
pas du tout une pépère à six qui bouge
pas d'après vous c'est quoi son métier
c'est beau comme on appelle ça compteur
baratineur il aime bien parler il aurait
pu faire autre chose comme métier avocat
vous êtes un peu la même chose mais ils
gagnent plus d'argent aux clientèles qui
est fidèle vous l'aimez bien cet homme
oui
vous le regardez pas souvent un nom
quand même quand je me maquille aux
cadres je fais très vite 1
c'est quoi la différence principale
entre l'homme que vous voyez dans le
miroir et vous n'y en a pas
elle n'a pas le je le vois pas de
différence vous avez ce que disent et
cocteau les miroirs devrait réfléchir
deux fois avant de renvoyer leur image
chante aubry je l'évolué
ggd
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu